streamer yasuo was recently served the
season desist letter
it was filed by his ex-girlfriend bella
who wanted him to stop talking trash
about her online
the only problem is that the cease and
desist letter
and the law firm bella used to represent
her are both completely fake
and this might not be the first time
bella has threatened someone
using fake legal documents
[Music]
all right guys you know the deal scroll
down just don't don't pause the video
let it run
scroll down hit the subscribe button and
then while you're at it you might as
well hit the notification bell
so you never miss me ranting and raving
about a twitch story
ever again back on february 11th twitch
streamer yasuo
received what looked like a cease and
desist letter and if you don't know
a cease and desist is a legal document
sent from one person to another
basically saying hey i don't like what
you're doing or saying
so stop that [ __ ] or i'll take you to
court and according to yasuo
this cease and desist letter was from
his ex-girlfriend bella
who wanted him to stop talking trash
about her online the only problem
the seasoned desist letter was
completely fake so after talking to our
lawyers they figured they're like okay
this seems very very sus like our
lawyers messaged us and they're like if
i'm gonna be completely real with you
there's a very high chance that this is
not a real legal document i
he's he i remember these words he pretty
much said like i don't think any
attorney would actually write this
write this so what we decided to do is
contact foundation law corporation
because that's the letter head that was
used right it was foundation law
corporation as you guys can see the flc
we message them and we're like yo we
received this following cease and desist
dating to be from your law firm
can you please confirm its legitimacy
they said this is not from our office
we're a law firm based in vancouver
canada
and the address at the bottom of this
letter i think it might be a full from a
law firm in los
angeles but i do think this letter is
quite strange that it is using our logo
lawyers and my firm are now aware of
this issue and we are looking into it
thanks for letting us know so at this
point we realized
they sent us a fake cease and desist now
before i explain
how fake this letter actually is let's
talk about why it was sent in the first
place back around october of 2020 yasuo
and bella dated
and eventually broke up a short while
later bella started dating cat evolved
the former mid laner for tsm's academy
team and it's here
where a bunch of drama that eventually
led to that fake cease and desist letter
started after cat evolved and bella
started dating bella started subtweeting
yasuo on twitter and katavolv started
flaming him whenever he could
it happened at a recent twitch rivals
event with cat evolved
passive-aggressively trolling yasuo and
allchat
and apparently he also did it during
solo queue
it's a classic case of the new boyfriend
stirring up [ __ ] with the old boyfriend
and eventually yasuo spoke about the
situation on stream
i've been getting subtweeted by my
ex-girlfriend bella for for a while now
when we broke up she started tweeting
about me about how money doesn't build
character
and how i'm a bad person or whatever cat
evolved tries [ __ ] talking me every time
we're against each other in league
he should talk me in rivals i muted him
i didn't even type back or talk about
him
i solo killed him i still didn't say a
word he kills me in solo queue like
two days ago and he starts typing in all
chat again it's pretty cringe like
you're supposed to be in your
relationship you're supposed to be happy
in that same stream yasuo talks about
how cat evolved allegedly recorded and
then
leaked a conversation between the two of
them something yasuo didn't know about
at the time
he recorded a private phone call between
me and him
which is illegal number one not only did
he record it on stream
record it and that's illegal he played
it on stream which is also illegal
and it's worth mentioning that this
isn't the first time cat evolved has
been
called out for his less than ideal
behavior
he's been accused of creating a script
to spam the n-word in chat
as well as just straight up ignoring
past twitch rivals teams
and not showing up for scrims so this
back and forth between bella
cat evolved and yasuo went on for a
while throughout the end of 2020 and
into 2021
and to be fair yasuo is no saint when it
comes to [ __ ] posting either
he cracked a bunch of jokes about the
situation to sanchovi's his friend and
fellow content creator
and referred to bella as his sloppy
seconds
then he got gapped in rivals i still
didn't say a word i just muted him
because i'm a real one then today i play
solo against his mother
he kills me lane katarina broken us i'm
gonna tell you that much by the way
and he types yawn yawn yeah and then
people in my chat were telling me
they're like
yo why is this chat saying you cheated
on her and i said i wish
and it's this moment that escalated
things towards that fake cease and
desist letter that i mentioned earlier
bella tweeted out that yasuo was being
misogynistic for saying stuff like that
cat evolved eventually chimed in and the
whole situation was left that
essentially stop talking [ __ ] or else
at this point it's early february just a
few weeks ago when this most recent
drama happened
and then on february 11th the world
learned about this fake cease and desist
letter
and yasuo jumped on stream to talk about
it but basically received the letter of
cease and desist
public defamatory statements and
incitement of violence and harassment
on my twitch.tv public account against
mr jackson dohan and bella
their legal counsel they write in
regards to the public statements
painting mr
dohan and whatever that you made several
live streams so pretty much they sent me
a cease and desist
and they wanted me to delete everything
they wanted me to send the public
apology
they wanted me never to mention their
name and they're asking for a lot of
things in it
which was a little odd but at the end of
the day like you know it's
their cease and desist they can ask for
whatever they want whether it makes
sense or doesn't make sense
now right at the beginning of this story
i told you about how that letter turned
out to be completely
fake yasuo's roommate and manager
ibrahim said that the letter was full of
spelling mistakes the phone numbers
weren't real
and the logos used for the law firm were
all super
blurry despite the red flags yasuo still
took this legal document seriously
and passed it along to his legal team
also i want to mention my lawyers ain't
cheap okay i know they aren't paying
much because
they're writing out their own cease and
desists but i'm paying an actual law
firm and a whole legal team to deal with
this
because this isn't a [ __ ] joke you
can't just break the law consistently
and get away with it that's just not how
that works
and remember yasuo reached out to the
very real law firm based in vancouver
canada that bella impersonated
and now they're looking into the
situation as well the funniest thing to
come out of all of this
is when yasuo did a photo shoot at the
address of the very
non-existent la based law firm
which turned out to be a restaurant now
i'm
clearly not a lawyer but holy [ __ ] i
don't think you can go around
serving people fake legal documents in
addition to discovering that the letter
was fake
yasuo's legal team also discovered that
bella's not 24 like she
said as you know i'm 21 years old
cat evolved is 19 years old and
we were under the impression that
she was 24 years old
she's actually a lot older than him um
and we found out that the age gap
is actually 10 years in two months she's
going to be 10 years older than him
and she has been lying about her age
this whole entire time
yasuo also said that this is allegedly
not the first time
bella has threatened people with a fake
cease and desist letter
in fact according to him she's done it a
lot
but i'm not the only person obviously
involved i'm sure you guys have seen
countless other youtubers like
pants or dragon that has been harassed
or bullied by them or threatened
gamer girl who was flamed and
like bullied on stream for just laughing
at something a situation professor akali
made his own video of talking about how
he's been manipulated himself
my old manager justin was been being
harassed and bullied by them
jesus was being [ __ ] threatened on
twitter riot
as you can see was being threatened with
legal documents fun of legends haim
coconut
all these highlight channels were also
being threatened with these legal
documents that they claim that they're
gonna send out
here's the tweet from riot bra that
yasuo mentioned
and it shows two photos from bella
allegedly threatening them with the same
fake
law firm that she threatened yasuo with
from there on monday february 15th
cat evolved apologized to yasuo on
stream i
i will just like apologize i already
apologized
irl to moe's manager ibrahim and i told
him
to like extend the apology to mo if he
hasn't already
then mo i am sorry everything happens
he also stated that he had no idea bella
faked this cease and desist letter
and that they broke up soon after he
found out so there you have it
bella deleted her twitter yasuo's still
doing backflips on twitch
there have been 8 000 youtube drama
videos made about this
and people are still munching on their
popcorn waiting for whatever's gonna
happen
next do you hear that reyna just got
nerfed
into oblivion did she and they finally
nerfed the stinger so you're
they nerfed devin oh i'm [ __ ] yeah so
this was
[ __ ] running shoot like call of duty
yeah this is you know
patch devin nerf
like yeah i'm just for contacts devon
literally bought the stinger over the
band
like so i just i shouldn't even i'm just
going to uninstall
valerie right now like i just shouldn't
even play anymore i i just have to break
the game in other ways now
dude i i've heard there's i heard the
bucky the shotgun is actually pretty
inside oh [ __ ] there we go
all right just time to transition to the
shop just hold hold like
absolute rat angles and and shoot people
yeah yeah all right well i'll give it a
shot
try to measure my head help
can i like all right
what the [ __ ] is it even know how to use
it